joining us now is florida governor ron
desantis governor thanks for being with
us
just yesterday you signed an anti-riot
bill
that you say is the strongest
law against writing pro-law enforcement
piece of legislation in the country
now given what we heard from biden and
harris tonight regarding
this push for the george floyd policing
act
is your law even necessary
well laura i think our law was was
necessary
we've seen a lot of unrest in our
country we don't want that coming to
florida
and it really does a lot of different
things i mean one of the things it does
is it effectively prevents local
governments
from defunding law enforcement which is
an insane idea
and would put a lot of people at risk it
also lets citizens sue their local
governments
if the local governments tell the police
to stand down during one of these things
and either they're harmed or their
property is harmed and it does provide
really strong penalties for people who
engage in violent assemblies
particularly
if you harm somebody else and
particularly if you harm a law
enforcement officer so
we're proud of what we did we think
it'll make a big difference
now in the angle i talked about how the
big lie that was told
over and over today by activists media
types
and the president and vice president is
that america
at her core is a racist nation
your thoughts on that continued
repetition and that drumbeat especially
as it affects young americans
well i think it's very damaging because
it delegits attempt to delegitimize
all the institutions in our country
starting with the constitution they say
they denigrate the founding fathers they
denigrate everybody in society now
so i think it's very harmful that's one
of the reasons in florida
we've banned critical race theory being
taught in our k-12 schools
we think teaching people to hate the
country hate each other based on race
is not a recipe for success and so we
don't believe that that's consistent
with what the country stands for a
protester
in new york city governor tonight made
it pretty clear
why a bill like yours is necessary watch
what we really have to be cognizant of
is that it was a mixture of
violent and non-violent protest
that yielded this result that's the
bottom line
america doesn't listen to us when we
march
peacefully i'm not saying people will be
back in the street
but america must know that if you
continue to allow us to be
murdered in the streets without justice
we will raise
hell in america governor
uh this isn't stopping anytime soon
as he indicated violence at least in
part worked
in in his view well that's really really
troubling laura because if that's what a
lot of people think and
i don't know what happened with this
verdict but if that's something that can
potentially happen where you basically
have justice
meted out because the jury is scared
of what a mob may do and again i'm not
saying that's what happened here
but that speaker seemed to suggest that
that had an impact
that's completely uh antithetical to the
rule of law
and i gotta i think what we've done with
our bill or any riot bill
is saying uh you know you engage in that
you're going to jail you're not gonna
gain
uh by doing that uh we we're gonna
maintain law and order but
certainly to think that somehow that is
going to
influence how the rule of laws applied
is it would be a total disaster if that
idea takes hold
now one of your state senators chevron
jones
not a big fan of your anti-riot bill
our response to injustices in this
country is protests
but their response is to criminalize it
when the recourse for us is to turn to
the streets
to make our voices heard in this unjust
system
governor desantis's actions today goes
to show
that he's not concerned about the lives
of black and brown
people you have just declared war on the
first amendment
in the state of florida governor
does this bill threaten floridians first
amendment
right to peaceably assemble
not at all i mean if you're throwing a
brick at a law enforcement officer's
head which many people were doing
throughout the summer
that has nothing to do with the first
amendment if you break into a store
and damage people's property or steal
people's property
doesn't have anything to do for with the
first amendment if you have a mob of
people defend
uh descend on an innocent civilian and
intimidate and harass them
doesn't have anything to do with the
first amendment and so
i think that this was a really necessary
piece of legislation and
look if you oppose the piece of
legislation
that means you want local governments to
be able to defund
police you want local governments to
have no consequence
if they allow people to be harmed and
not have police there
and it means you don't want strong
penalties for people who are engaging in
violent activities and so i think we got
it right
and you know sometimes when you get the
criticism you know you're over the
target
you know when they start launching wild
accusations
do you feel like you are being targeted
now
maybe because of you're running for
re-election next year
as governor and people are talking about
you as a possible 2024
candidate do you feel like after the 60
minutes and
that you're now in their sights with
trump at least temporarily uh
you know off the grid well we've been in
the sites for about a year laura because
the kovid
we went in a different direction than
what the narrative and the media were
demanding
they were predicting that florida would
be the worst and they had all this
and i think that the fact that we did it
a different way
we've obviously been much more
successful our coveted mortalities less
than the national average and yet our
unemployment's much less than the
national average
and we've had kids in school all year in
person
they do not want to admit that their
approach was wrong and that our approach
was more effective
so i think we've been dealing with this
for a long time you know obviously 60
minutes was a
was a total hatchet job and that's blown
up in their face
clearly they were trying to target me
during that but
the good news is is they didn't really
find anything of merit and so they had
to lie
and they had to edit stuff out and so i
think we came out and most people
realized i was right governor great to
see you tonight thanks so much
thank you